reading whether technical or for
personal learning is a part of the
process of becoming less wrong about the
world you come into a book with some
background knowledge priors learn new
information gather data and update your
beliefs to more closely match reality of
posterior try to choose books that teach
you something and that you also find
intriguing by Will Corson towards data
science and data science conversation so
hi I'm Schultz FASA secretary or PhD
student and today I really want to show
you my method of finding and Gathering
new information from articles and
putting it all into this big research
bank and I created this research banquet
notion because I personally really like
notion as you know and I find it really
nice and intuitive tool to use to gather
all my ideas so it's a system that I
really use to capture new ideas and also
to kind of gather and create new ideas
from this information and I think if you
have to read a lot of Articles as a
student or you have to write a lot of
papers this method will really help you
and will really allow you to get really
creative with the research process so
first of all I gather all my ideas in a
research Bank there are three main
reasons that I personally really love
creating this kind of research Bank in
Ocean and that is first of all to not
forget all the material I have read
Because I read so many articles and
books throughout the year that to
remember everything I've read ever and
also the places where I found this
information is really hard so because I
all have it in one place which is my
research bank I tend to not forget all
the material I've read and the second
reason I love a research bank is that it
really allows me to make connections
between new ideas because usually when I
read something in an article or I find a
new idea it doesn't immediately occur to
me how I would connect it to a bigger
picture of a big project I'm usually
working on but because I have these
ideas for a long time in my research
Bank it usually allows me to make new
and Creative Connections that I have not
thought of before and the last reason
for a research bank is the most obvious
reason I think and that to just have one
place where all your ideas and
everything you've ever read in your
entire life kind of comes together and
it kind of becomes like your own library
of ideas that you have read throughout
your life so I'm gonna show you in this
video an example of how I've created
this research bank and I will do it
through a little bit less directed
reading because I think there are kind
of two forms of reading and that's
directed reading and undirected reading
and directed reading is usually when you
want to find an answer to a direct
question you have and I think this type
of reading is pretty straightforward
because you just have to find the answer
but I'm gonna talk a lot about
undirected reading and undirected
reading is just a type of reading you
have to do a lot as a student if you
have to read a lot of papers a lot of
books and kind of gather all of that
information and combine it somehow in a
new and creative way for your papers or
your research project and what I've
noticed is that people struggle a lot
more with undirected reading how to
really systemize this and gather the
ideas to combine it into a new projects
for example so in general in Reading
there are three main aspects that's
collecting retrieving and combining the
information so the first step of reading
is collecting or encountering new
information and data and I've personally
really systemized this process because I
think it's the part of the process that
can take the longest so when I read
articles I usually have three apps that
I always use that allow me to read many
articles throughout the year and really
speed up the process versus insta paper
the second is read wise and the third is
notion so first of all insta paper so I
usually find a lot of my papers on
Twitter for example or medium when I'm
just browsing the internet so a lot of
the articles that I read I just
encounter naturally and then the way I
gather them is by using insta paper so
insta paper has this kind of Web Clipper
app so it's this add-on on Google Chrome
and you can just click it and then every
time you encounter a nice article that
you want to read later you click this
add-on and then it gathers this
information in this really nice
newsletter format and the way I do it is
then every day I take about an hour and
usually that's an hour when my code is
running on the background or an hour in
the morning and I go through my insta
paper on my phone iPad or computer and
just really take this hour to highlight
certain parts of articles that I like so
the nice feature of insta paper at least
I find is that it's really this daily
type of newsletter and it allows you to
really highlight articles pretty easily
and also another thing I really
personally like is it says how long it
will approximately take you to read an
article so I know if I have a few short
minutes I can read an article on my
phone or if I have a little bit longer I
can deep dive into an article on my
computer so after this I have all these
highlights from my insta paper but the
thing I want to do is gather all these
highlights automatically into one place
and that's that's where the Second Step
comes in read wise but what read wise
then does is it collects all the
highlights you've made into one place
and you can then go through your
highlights at your own liter or you can
look at them and kind of see what you've
highlighted throughout the years but
what I don't like to do is this first
step and that's to transfer it over to
notion so maybe if you've watched my
video on notion you know that I really
use notion as kindness this second brain
or research bank and that's because I
really like notion's flexibility like it
allows me to put in a lot of information
and also to play with this information
in any way I want so on read wise you
have this automatic notion integration
surface so it automatically transfers
every highlight you made to your notion
page so I can show you real quick what
that looks like for example this is my
read wise page on notion so read wise
automatically made this page for me and
here you can see some of the highlights
I have from podcast so for example this
is from the anthropocene reviewed which
is a podcast I really recommend it's by
John Green and it's super super good so
here you can see a small snippet that I
made but the nice thing of read wise is
it does the same with tweets for example
so I also collect
um tweets usually and for example also
articles so here you can see some of the
articles I have done this with so one
article I read recently was this
Collective Minds social network topology
shapes Collective cognition a super good
article I really recommend it and I made
these highlights then on Insta paper and
then what read wise does for me it
collects these highlights and then as
you can see here it puts all these
highlights automatically into notion so
yeah I really like this method because I
think this type of integration and
automatically having it in your notion
really allows you to become quite
creative and really catch a lot of ideas
that you just encounter so the main part
of this part of the person says it's not
really to understand or to think about
ideas really deeply but it's mostly to
capture new ideas that would spark your
creativity or your curiosity and another
way for me that really for me excites me
and Sparks creativity is learning new
languages so this video is also kindly
sponsored by linguda so I take a lot of
inspiration from quotes and from other
languages that I've learned so I've
learned in my life a lot of languages
but one that I'm working on currently is
French and one thing that I personally
find really important when learning a
language is that you not only passively
learn the language but you also Deep
dive into the language and I personally
really recommend to do this with native
speakers I think being able to talk with
native speakers really increases your
ability to learn a new language quickly
and to become fluently quite quick so
with linguda what I like is that I'm
able to fit it into my super busy
schedule because I can select my own
language classes and that really allows
me to slowly increase my abilities by
speaking with Native speakers and also
something that I really like is that you
can choose your own topics that you're
interested in so they kind of have this
set course curriculum which gives some
structure but throughout that curriculum
you can also jump around between
different topics and really select
topics that you like so for example
during the holidays and in the weekend
I'm slowly trying to make it a habit to
learn one Topic in French a week I'm not
really there yet but I do try to keep up
this habit such that I can also talk
with my friends abroad in a while so
right now lingoda also offers this seven
day trial with which you can take three
group lessons or one private lesson
completely for free and also if you
decide to sign up afterwards with
linkuda I do have this discount code
down below that gives you 30 off of your
first payments so if you're learning a
language as well right now I would love
to know which language you're learning
so please put it down in the comments
below and otherwise let's get back to
the video so after the first step you
have now your research Bank in notion
and then the second step is really to
reach retrieve this information so
something that I've noticed is that it
is really hard sometimes to go over the
information again so sometimes we have
the tendency to collect a lot of
information but to never look at it
again so I have a few methods that I use
to kind of overcome this problem and one
thing that I really do is usually that
when I'm working on a new paper or a new
big project I will go over most of my
notes and just see what kind of clicks
with a new project that I'm making so
when I was working on auto encoders
there I was also going over my notes at
that time and one quote that for example
for me really clicked was this one and
that's truly conscious ignorance is a
Prelude to every real advance in science
and somehow for me that kind of
connected with Auto encoders and it
could be that for you this doesn't
connect at all right but I think this
part of the process is a little bit more
creative so this is usually what I do I
or go over my notes when I'm in an
active projects or sometimes what I also
am working on right now is to try to
work with this New Concept that I call a
slip box and I have the idea from
Elizabeth Phillips another YouTuber that
I personally really like and what she
does is that once every half year she
goes over all the notes and she puts it
in this so-called slip box so this is an
example of a slip box that I've made um
some of them are a little bit bigger but
I put it into topics that I find
important so for an example one topic
that I find important is wisdom and then
I have subjects that for me fall under
wisdom so that's extreme value Theory
Mind Body Connection statistics machine
learning and then what I do is I go over
all my notes in my read twice app and I
connect them to the different subtopics
that I have in this slip box so for
example the Hall of Presidents and a new
partner that falls is a note that I've
made from the enterprising reviewed and
if I find that if it's with the topic of
wisdom and extreme value Theory I will
put it under that and this process takes
me quite long so I would say I don't do
this too often I do this about once
every two three months or when I really
see that I've gathered a lot of notes
and that I kind of need to clean them or
kind of need to review them and then the
third step that I kind of want to go
over and that's to really try to
creatively use all the information you
have gathered so you've now have your
research Bank you've retrieved the
information and then the last step is to
really combine them and allow you to
creatively play with these ideas and the
main idea I usually keep in mind with
this part of the process is how can this
idea help me in my research or my
projects that I'm working with and the
way I do it is that I usually try to
incorporate all the ideas that I've just
retrieved into active projects I have
right now so that can be that I'm
teaching someone something and I'm going
over all of these ideas in my slipbox
and see if I can gather some of the
quotes to kind of make my points more
clear or I will use it in papers that
I'm writing so if I'm writing a paper at
that moment I will also go to my slipbox
look at the part of wisdom for example
and try to gather some quotes or some
ideas that really that really for me
allowed to convey an idea that I've put
in my paper writing process and also I
think a good idea is just to keep it in
the Forefront when you're discussing
something for example with friends and I
think by doing this I'm really playing
with these ideas you will kind of see
that the amount of information and how
good you become in a topic will increase
dramatically this seems like a really
slow process but I think if you do this
over a couple of months you will see
that you will really start to remember a
lot of the ideas that you've gathered
and also people will kind of come to
really respect some of the ideas that
you connect because I think the ability
to connect abstract ideas is what really
sets apart someone that is a really good
researcher or an interesting student
from someone that just follows the
normal lines of the book and if you're
also working on creating a research bank
or you have other methods that you use
to do it I would love to hear that so
put that down in the comments below
because I always try to optimize my
process as well and otherwise see you
next week bye